Our Muslim friends insist that according
to the Quran, the Bible was
corrupted. The problem is that the Quran
never once says that the text of the
Bible was corrupted. The Quran claims
that people misinterpret and
misrepresent and even hide what the
Bible says, but it never even suggests
that the text of the Bible has been
changed. On the contrary, the Quran
affirms the inspiration, the
preservation, and the authority of the
Jewish and Christian scriptures. In
fact, according to the Quran, only one
of Allah's books has ever been
corrupted. This book has been so
utterly, totally, completely corrupted
that the Quran declares it was shredded.
And I don't mean shredded like Wes Huff.
I mean shredded like a block of cheese
on Taco Tuesday. Let's read. Surah 15:es
90 to91 to see which of Allah's books
has been shredded, fragmented, torn to
pieces, ripped apart, dismembered. Since
this is such an important issue, we'll
read multiple translations to make sure
we understand what the Quran is
claiming. We'll start with the MH Shakir
translation.
Like as we sent down on the dividers,
those who made the Quran into
shreds. By golly, it's the Quran. The
Quran is the book that was shredded.
Shredded like the love letters from one
of Muhammad Hijab's disgruntled ex hotel
wives. Let's read the Ysef Ali
translation.
of just such wrath as we sent down on
those who divided scripture into
arbitrary parts. So also on such as have
made Quran into shreds as they
please as they please. They did whatever
they wanted to the Quran. Perhaps these
were the men of Alz having their way
with the Quran like they had their way
with the fake prophet who delivered it.
What about the Arbory
translation? So he sent it down to the
practitioners who have broken the Quran
into
fragments. They broke the Quran into
fragments. No wonder the Quran seems so
disorganized and incoherent and
confused. All we've got are
fragments. Now for the Palmer
translation. as we sent down punishment
on the separatists who dismember the
Quran. Oh, the
irony. The Quran commands its adherence
to dismember people for all kinds of
vague reasons. But people ended up
dismembering the Quran in return. Fair
is fair, I guess. So, the Quran has been
shredded, fragmented, dismembered.
Isn't it interesting that the harshest
language the Quran uses about any book
is used not about the Bible but about
the Quran
itself. But what does Allah mean when he
says that the Quran has been shredded,
fragmented,
dismembered? Let's read the passage in
context. Even though this probably won't
help since the Quran is quite frequently
hopelessly unclear, but let's try. We'll
read it in the study Quran. Earlier in
surah 15, Allah explains how he punished
various groups for not obeying his
messengers. Then he says to Muhammad in
verse 88, "Strain not thine eyes toward
the enjoyments we have bestowed upon
certain classes of them, and grieve not
for them, and lower thy wing unto the
believers, and say, truly I am the clear
warner." Such as we have sent down for
those who make division, who made the
Quran into fragments. So by thy Lord, we
shall question them all concerning that
which they used to do. So proclaim as
thou hast been commanded, and turn away
from the
idoltors. So what does this part mean?
such as we have sent down for those who
make division, who made the Quran into
fragments. Sadly, you won't figure it
out from the shredded, fragmented,
dismembered Quran, but at least you can
understand why Ysef Ali added so much
parenthetical commentary to try to make
sense of it. Fortunately, we've got
plenty of commentary in the study Quran.
Let's try to make sense of the Quran
being shredded, fragmented,
dismembered. Verse 90 can be connected
with verse 89 such that together they
could be read to mean notice could be
read to mean i.e. they don't really
know. I am a clear warner to you of a
punishment like the punishment that
visited those who make division. The
letters in parenthesis refer to Muslim
commentators. Those who make division
may refer may refer meaning they don't
know to a group of mechans who were
stationed on the outskirts of Mecca by
al-wali ibn al-mira one of the main
enemies of the prophet in order to tell
people entering Mecca that there was a
man in Mecca who was claiming
prophethood but who was in reality a
possessed magician soothsayer and poet.
It may also be may also be meaning they
don't know a more general reference to
the mechan idoltors who rejected the
Quran. Thus those who made the Quran
into fragments refers to the mechans who
rejected the Quran by calling it sorcery
fables of the ancients or soothsaying
rather meaning that it was not a whole
but rather was cobbled together from
these false sources. Others say others
say meaning they don't know that those
who made the Quran into fragments refers
to those who believe in the parts of the
Quran they like and reject the rest. So
we have a bunch of theories from a bunch
of Muslim commentators about what the
Quran means when it says that people
shredded, fragmented, and dismembered
it. But we'll never really know what it
means because even though the Quran
claims to be clear, it most certainly
isn't. And the explanations we get in
Muslim commentaries are a bunch of later
interpretations from people who were
cooking up theories left and right in
order to try to make sense of Allah's
shockingly unclear, clear speech. Now, I
ordinarily wouldn't have much of a
problem with Muslim commentaries
offering different explanations for what
a verse means. There are Jewish
commentaries that offer different
explanations for verses of the Torah.
There are Christian commentaries that
offer different explanations for verses
of the Gospels. So, why am I drawing
attention to an unclear passage in the
Quran with a bunch of conflicting Muslim
commentaries? Three reasons. First, as I
mentioned, the Quran claims to be clear
and it just isn't. Even in a passage
about the Quran being shredded and
fragmented and dismembered. The Quran
claims to be clear. And Surah 15 90-91
sounds like it's saying that something
really bad happened to the Quran.
Second, if you bring this passage up to
one of your Muslim friends, he'll have
absolutely no clue what it means because
he's never read it. What will he do?
He'll ask his favorite da guy about it.
And that da guy will respond by quoting
a
commentary. But the da guy won't tell
your Muslim friend that different Muslim
commentators give completely different
explanations for what the passage is
about. He'll quote whatever commentary
is most convenient and he'll pretend
that the matter is settled and that the
Quran is clear. Dawa is all smoke and
mirrors.
Third, these same da guys will go to
dozens of passages in the Quran that
affirm the inspiration, the
preservation, and the authority of the
Bible, and they'll twist and distort all
of them just to cover up the fact that
the Quran affirms the Bible. They'll
quote verses that have nothing to do
with the preservation of the Bible and
flat out lie about them to make them
sound like they're saying the Bible was
corrupted.
And they'll do this knowing that the
harshest, most negative language the
Quran ever uses about any book is when
it says that the Quran was
shredded. Let's face it, if Surah 15:es
90 to 91 said that the Bible was
shredded, fragmented, and
dismembered, this would be the main
passage Muslims go to when they claim
that the Bible was corrupted. They'd
say, "You see, the Quran says that the
Bible was shredded. This is the
proof." But it doesn't say Bible. It
says Quran. So, it can't possibly mean
anything
negative. This is borderline insane.
Dagandists expect everyone to believe
that when the Quran says it was
shredded, it means it was perfectly
preserved. and that when the Quran
affirms the inspiration, preservation,
and authority of the Bible, it means the
Bible was
corrupted. We're dealing with compulsive
liars. They could get away with it 20
years ago when the world was almost
completely ignorant about Islam, but the
world is catching on. Dawa, like the
Quran, has been shredded, fragmented,
and dismembered.
We're the ones who shredded, fragmented,
and dismembered it. And we're just
getting started. Be sure to screenshot
and share Surah 15 90 to 91. And don't
leave without watching another video.
[Music]